well still to come on the show we'll be
hearing from the head of Ofsted plus
I've spoken to people on both sides of
the heated debate about HST but first
for three years Northern Ireland was
without a devolved government but after
a deal brokered by the UK and Irish
governments an executive and assembly
was reformed three weeks ago we're
joined now by the First Minister of
Northern Ireland Arlene Foster thank you
very much for being on the program at
Miss posture
well we're now officially out of the
European Union we heard a little earlier
from the Foreign Secretary Dominic Rob
being pretty clear that the government
wants to diverge from the EU are you
worried that this could mean more checks
between Northern Ireland and the rest of
the UK
well good morning Sophie yes we have
left the European Union but
unfortunately for those of us who live
in Northern Ireland we are going to be
still the subject to single market
regulations and it's important now for
us to get clarity on what that actually
means for us in Northern Ireland in
relation to future trade deals I'm
indeed what's going to happen when goods
are coming from Great Britain into
Northern Ireland because of course we
rely heavily on goods coming from Great
Britain and Northern Ireland I think
about 70% of all the goods that come
over into Northern Ireland come from
Great Britain and of course we're
concerned about that we worry about the
fact that it might reduce our choice in
terms of consumer choice in Northern
Ireland we're worried about price and
the fact that it may put up prices in
Northern Ireland and of course the very
fundamental issue of having checks
internally within a country is of great
concern to me as a unionist I mean Boris
Johnson said that there won't be checks
but of course if he does really want to
diverge from the EU to the extent that
we're led to believe it's quite hard to
see how that could happen I mean do you
trust Boris Johnson on this well we've
heard Boris Johnson say this right
throughout the issue he told one of my
colleagues in the House of Commons that
emphatically there would not be checks
but it's difficult to see how that is
the case given that we've heard from
other members of the cabinet that they
intend to diverge away from single
market regulations whilst Northern
Ireland remains within the single market
stiffly
to see how that's going to work but
we're in Northern Ireland now working
through what's called the joint
Ministerial Council where we meet with
colleagues from Scotland and Wales and
from the Westminster government to try
and work through all of these matters
because it is a huge issue for us not
just in Northern Ireland but of course
we'll have impacts in Scotland and Wales
as well and in England in terms of their
ports what's going to happen there when
the goods are coming over from Great
Britain into Northern Ireland
I mean Boris Johnson is talking a lot
about sovereignty at the moment are you
worried that he's preparing to kind of
sell out Northern Ireland in order to
get what he wants when it comes to
sovereignty I mean it's one of the
issues why I supported rex at
sovereignty the fact that we could have
control over our border our laws and our
money again in the United Kingdom it's
it's the key reason actually why I
supported leaving the European Union so
for those of us in Northern Ireland it's
very important that that sovereignty
runs as well into this part of the UK
it's important that we are still in the
United Kingdom's Customs Code of course
that's the fundamental difference
between trees and maize daily Boris
Johnson sail but the the issue then
arises around these single market
regulations and how they're going to
impact our trade from Great Britain into
Northern Ireland and that's what we want
to see clarity on in the coming months
okay now power sharing of is of course
back up and running in Northern Ireland
why do you think it took so long to get
to this point well that's a very good
question for our part we were always
prepared to go back into government
again and I suppose we could spend the
rest of the interview talking about what
happened over this past three years but
for for me it's important that we look
forward that we deal with all of the
challenges that we have because we
haven't had a government here for three
years principally those arise in our
national health service the fact that we
have the longest waiting lists anywhere
in the United Kingdom and we need to
deal with those issues and to focus on
what we have in front of us instead of
looking backwards I mean the deal that
restored and power-sharing all state
included this promise by the Westminster
government to implement something called
the Stormont house agreement now that's
an agreement from 2014
where the government commits to setting
up this historical investigations unit
to investigate deaths during the
Troubles au worries that this could mean
fresh investigations into British troops
well I think the Stormont house
agreement is five years old now nearly
six years old it's important that we
look at all of the consultation
responses that came in from various
victims groups so to see what they want
and I think we need to revisit the
Stormont house agreement because what
has been proposed and we made this clear
in our consultation response at the time
what is being proposed is not acceptable
I think to the victims grips here and
it's certainly not acceptable to us so
there needs to be a relook at the
Stormont house agreement particularly in
relation to the remit of the historical
institution the hiu which is there to
look at historical cases do UK
government is perhaps under estimating
how serious this could potentially be no
I think they're very much aware of how
serious this issue is this is a legacy
issue from 1990 at the Belfast agreement
victims were not treated well in the
Belfast agreement that was left as an
open wouldn't we now have been left with
nearly 22 years later we're still
dealing with these issues there is a
need to deal with these issues I
absolutely agree with that but it has to
be done in a way that recognizes
fairness and recognises what actually
happened here in Northern Ireland over
3540 years the fact that we did have a
terrorist campaign and there were so
many innocent victims as a result of
that I mean Boris Johnson says he won't
will end vexatious claims do you trust
him that he'll be able to do that well I
hope that he will be able to do that but
I hope that he does it in a way that
recognizes not just soldiers and British
soldiers who live on the mainland but
also he takes into account those people
who continue to live here in Northern
Ireland security force members who
continue to live here in Northern
Ireland need to be protected as well
from vexatious claims I think that is
very important so we will be continuing
the conversation with government about
legacy issues we'll be continuing the
conversation obviously an executive
about these issues as well now that the
executive is back but as I say this is a
running sore that runs from 1998 and at
some
thing that does need to be sorted out
now I've been talking of course about
the Duvall government the restoration or
fire in Northern Ireland and of course
the executive collapsed in part the
course of this renewable energy scheme
where a businesses were encouraged to
switch to renewable energy but it
actually ended up wasting 500 million
pounds of taxpayers money is it right
that three years later you're back as
First Minister
are you sorry well of course there is a
public inquiry which hasn't yet come to
the fore that public inquiry will bring
forward a report and we will learn and
adapt from that public inquiry report I
think it's important that we do learn
the lessons from that area but you know
at the time that the executive collect
collapsed there were wild and frenzied
allegations around about a number of
people I think it's important that we
have the report from the public inquiry
which will deal with all of those issues
and we look forward to that coming in
the near future
500 million pounds a lot of money they
are you not sorry well it's not actually
we're on an understand situation in
relation to the Renewable Heat Incentive
scheme because we took I mean when
people talk about five hundred thousand
pounds up was the projected figure if we
hadn't have intervened and dealt with
the issue we did deal with the issue and
no there isn't an overspend in fact
there is an understand in relation to
this scheme so I think when people throw
about those sorts of figures they really
need to look at the fact the fact was
that was a projected amount of money
that's now not going to happen and in
fact we're in an understand situation
what's the Westminster Government okay
now we could be looking at HS - a little
bit later in the programme Boris Johnson
has been promising some big
infrastructure spending one of the ideas
that he didn't meet once was this idea
of a bridge linking Northern Ireland to
the UK mainland is that something that
you'd like him to be considering well I
think it is important that we look at
infrastructure projects and not only
look at them but actually look at how
they're delivered and one of the
difficulties with HS two is the fact
that it is overrun spectacularly and
that's not unusual unfortunately with
infrastructure projects and there's a
need to look at how those are delivered
right across the United Kingdom but if
we are to look at rebalancing the United
Kingdom
because of course there are only three
regions of the UK economy which are net
contributors to the economy and those
are all in one part of the UK down in
the southeastern on them if we are to
rebalance the economy across the United
Kingdom then there needs to be
interventions and one of those
interventions is to have better
infrastructure so I support the
government in putting money into
infrastructure but it has to be done in
a way that we get value for money and it
has to be done in a way that it's
project managed in the correct fashion
so do you like no I do for bridge then
well I think it should be scoped out I
think we should be ambitious in relation
to all of our infrastructure projects I
don't think it's the complete priority
for the Northern Ireland Executive F I'm
entirely honest but I think that we
should look at ambitious projects
because in the past when we have
ambitious projects those were the ones
that made the the difference if you like
to our economy okay Arlene Foster thank
you very much for coming on the program
this morning thank you thank you